about to go in my bread welcome welcome
well oh [ __ ] I remember now we're
supposed to go in storage B why do I go
- Sarge me first I don't know but all I
know is this is our quality time
we already started in my it gives you
amazing nine eyes you don't like this I
should have cut this part it's just
started after this but then we couldn't
talk to each other you know but I'd
leave talk to I'm just kidding all right
whoa how long I thought I thought this
place would be nice this place is not
nice at all
miles this is [ __ ] terrifying
I can't see [ __ ] I adore how my [ __ ]
head I can't do everything here okay oh
it's going more down that is just
[ __ ] great oh this is [ __ ] creepy
man oh I got a feeling about that ha ha
ha ha oh [ __ ] Oh
ah we're going in here Oh mad I thought
there was gonna be a nice little puzzle
down here but nope
it's a shovel nice backflip eyebrow I
tended to tea I'll pick it up a doodie
let's hi hi how you doing shovels hi how
you doing hey give it a little pattern
yep they're pretty you're pretty well
there is nothing in they why don't we
got potatoes I got the power I look at
the boxes I don't like this place
I don't I don't understand all right
we're going here hello okay I feel safer
now I feel like we're good hey Dennis oh
did I do double tinner today are we
supposed to find something air I don't
know
hey bro I could stick you up mama
oh I can stick it up his butt perfect or
bounce back hi hi what are you what the
[ __ ] are you hey right hey I stick it up
it ha ha Jania Spence
strikes again with its bunch poking oh
you like that [ __ ] don't you
oh no it fell out well you like I said
how the [ __ ] did I do that
holy [ __ ] I'm a dye dad and I got you're
coming with me [ __ ]
alright that's right right get out of
here
oh you like that [ __ ] you kinky bastard
not stop I'm eight come here alright
you're gonna poke some other [ __ ] the
bitch's holes
alright my going in here this is where
he went but I think because I have this
broom we're actually not bad I don't
trust it oh it's gonna be that ball I
have a broom I'm not afraid to poke your
[ __ ]
but it's going on in why is it slo-mo
why is it Zombo
my eye
what
okay
I don't even know all the [ __ ] well
it's like now what is this sound' boughs
they have surrounded me [ __ ] I didn't
ask for this
ah
no it's dark again what no no I have a
broom why do I don't ah no but no
there's no alive data box all right
we're good
can I move this maybe I can move this no
I can't
that is just great that is just great
that is just fun I am barricading this
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] you know my side
now you little [ __ ] oh he's not
coming in here I'll get the [ __ ] out of
the way then bro my I'm scared I need
something I don't care if you're a
[ __ ] broom I need something by my
side alright I have a broom I'm not
afraid of yells at
I don't like the pros I really don't
[ __ ] like this it's so [ __ ] dark
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I wish I wish I had
something else in this [ __ ] broom but
it's all we got
oh thank god okay why do we got in here
nice front flip my bro what is it Daniel
what is it what is it where is it where
our ass fire fire well there's a lot of
empty rooms in here and they're odd they
had a chef I was a little disappointed
that they don't give me goodies all
right I feel a little better now that we
have some light
what are you doing my man what are you
doing why don't we what are you doing
you just love all right down you got
balls
yeah the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] bats and
[ __ ] here huh oh this is a trap oh whoa
oh this is what I thought we were gonna
go [ __ ] Auto broom
ah
what do I do I gotta solve this puzzle
right how much too exposed I don't know
I feel that has been one since I said I
was a child you know I still cannot find
my way I've seen so much of this
accursed place I've been to escape a how
is storage rooms mechanical doors and
attractions ifs with the machinery of
this castle make me feel like it's an
organism that's the same when my feeble
attempts to free myself of its clutches
Adam I don't know my last place how does
that even make sense
how does that make sense I'm just a man
shoveling wood foodie
I don't even know why this again it I
can't even move these well it when it's
up with a while I expected more of that
[ __ ] alright well I guess I got what I
came from poor oh now it's the best part
of going back everyone knows going back
down calm down
no no no no but not even humanly
possible I'm sorry bro
wait darling my going my god
I know nobody's knowing I'm on going ah
[ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is the outside us Paradis
I know
that's it
Oh
what the [ __ ] is that ever possible
you know potatoes potatoes potatoes
don't sound bad
don't stop stop stop stop stop
what do you
Wow
Oh God oh he got me one shot you have to
Acharya oh that shit's intense man that
is [ __ ] intense oh we're back here
yeah yeah that's good bro I'm so sorry
you poked the battle's ass you are a
good man a good man sorry you're a woman
oh I'm sorry bro you don't have a name
yet I'll let the rest decide I don't
even know these days you didn't work
very well though I got it I gotta give
that to them to the to the bro get it
work [ __ ]
why did they even give you a broom it's
like penumbra when it gives you like if
you're a [ __ ] pro man it's like hike
a broom you know what you know you know
I'm saying I'm surprised people on mod
penumbra could you Marvin Umbra no [ __ ]
you brah
now whoa it's working oh my god I'm a
genius
go one nope
I am done with that [ __ ] I am so [ __ ]
done with that place I have never ever
been more done in a place before during
my episodes this mansion I find myself
in this other life saddens me
it smells familiar as I've I've been
there before but it's cold and lonesome
it's hopeless and despair Edison
Saturday I don't want to return and I'm
afraid of becoming trapped in that
frightening world forever and the
picture it was three of them not in this
one is only one so I'm a little bit like
what the [ __ ] alright where are the
pleasures of going and storage be a
whatever
don't judge me that was [ __ ] intense
that was so intense mime I don't even
know we gotta find it the third rod or
whatever to make the [ __ ] door open
mmm I don't even know anymore bras I
don't even know that was [ __ ]
terrifying I don't think that will Alice
nothing terrifying for me when the bro
wants my ass you know I'm saying you're
no one saying you don't know I can't
open my menu for some reason what is
this huh it's weird how well
what's going on here
what is why do I feel dizzy did he
implant drugs in May I loved her I mean
no drugs about what no my head is still
thing again
why is it doing this
ah what that why you gotta pass out your
pudding
such a pest
so this is our day to look before right
am i right
no just make or am I dreaming of some
last memories
it's [ __ ] what no no no no bad game
ah you know what oh oh it's me it's me I
did that okay cool
I can't get up and it doesn't mean it
has to be a they really made a quarter
nice in this game
like it I never appreciated it actually
looks kind of pretty there's the box
right there I'm taking it